Các cuộc hôm kênh giòn Mỹ tiến hành ngày hai 1 tháng 6, nhà bờ bác hơ dởi hạm nhân chủ chối của Yvân,
đều đánh xa đã gây giờ thì thảy nghiêm trọng, dù tổng thống nơi năng trang trên bố các mục tiêu đã bị xa sổ hoàn toàn.
Dởi chuyên gia chơi dành vẫn chưa thể xác mình tuần mỗi này,
hình anh vệ tên chưa thấy một số lối vào hầm bị xa,
sâm nhiều khu vực trọc yếu, vẫn không bị phá hủy hoàn toàn.
Tức quan đang lộng, mình tự của tỷ ía, kẹn báo,
các cuộc tấn công liên tiếp khiến nhận bố giám sát Uraní của Yvân trở nên khó khăn hơn.
Nếu chương xa chương xan, Yvân có thể sẽ chuyển trưng trình hạm nhân,
vào hạt động bý mật để giảm quyết tình tục tiếp theo.
Trong mối cảnh ngày EIA đã lên tiếng, kêu gọi chứng rất sào chân,
và chựa tập của học hình tại viên.
Tuy nhiên, tình hành gình thử biển ở tí tụt phức tạp với hòn gạm ngày càng xa tăng,
về khả năng Yvân không còn hực tắt minh bạc như trước,
với các quan giám sát hạm nhân của tế.